one of the strangest and most
tantalizing ideas in Psychotherapy is
that of the repetition
compulsion this tells us that as a
result of certain traumas that have not
been properly understood and unpicked we
will be inclined to keep putting
ourselves back into and in effect
repeating difficult situations from the
past that run counter to our emotional
needs in the present so for example we
may be tempted to keep falling in love
with people who make us suffer by being
distant or cold muddled or chaotic or we
might constantly wind up in jobs where
we try to please a tricky boss but then
we're rejected by them and eventually
dismissed but there's a Nuance here we
are not generally simply hunting out an
awful situation and then attempting to
repeat the whole of it what we're doing
is trying to find a story familiar
enough for us to be drawn to it and then
what we're attempting to do is to give
it a different ending so for example we
might want to find someone who is as
distant as our mother but this time we
want to take her to therapy we want to
have long dialogues with her help her to
see her wounds and act as her protector
and her guide or we want to find the
same sort of angry man as our father was
but this time rather than cing under the
sofa we want a chance to be a to get to
the root of their rage to appease it and
then ensure that they will treat us well
we are seeking in adulthood for a second
chance to rectify a traumatic Dynamic
that our unavoidable childhood
weaknesses meant that we were never
originally able to fix what does it mean
to give a story A better ending it means
bringing all the resources of adulthood
to bear on the difficulties of an
emotionally compromised childhood Ood
this idea of story completion lends us a
more hopeful angle to the concept of
repeating the past we aren't merely
driven by an urge to suffer we're being
motivated by something much more
creative a desire to identify something
in the here and now that is a bit broken
like it used to be and then we have a
wish to repair it with our adult
strengths in the hope of being able to
move on and finally find Freedom